[Applause]
hi drew i'm so excited congratulations
on your show
this is great thank you so much um i
love your family you know when i was a
kid
i worked for your grandfather the one
and only dino de laurentiis
to everyone he is a big famous italian
and hollywood movie producer
a pioneer an icon a bigwig and i did
fire starter and cat's eye with him and
i loved him
yeah i remember i think we met we were
both very very young when my grandfather
opened
his italian gourmet shop um here in l.a
called ddl food show
and you came to the opening and so did i
and i remember we were probably the only
kids there
giada maybe that's where my obsession
with you started
i don't know i don't think i i wasn't a
big i mean i was a
a young cook then i guess i'm excited
you're cooking
oh and i hear you like cacho pepe it's
my favorite
although i was freaking out about the
carbonara episode we were just looking
at
it was unbelievable the people that we
met but i think the funnest part
was being the translator for bobby it's
really great the show
it was it was a really fun fun show and
um it was just
fun for for us to also be able to show
our two perspectives
um in a city that i was born and i've
spent a lot of time at and that my
family still lives in
and for someone sort of who's been
passionate for so long
about italy and italian food and seeing
his perspective
and the way that you know the things
that he loves versus the things that i
love
i think that's the fun of the whole show
i'm just in love with it and by the way
we all need to
get out of our houses right now so thank
you for taking us there
yeah it's a nice little vacation now
wait where are you in this recipe
because my pasta my bucatini
is almost ready wait you're do you have
bucatini you don't have bucatini
you have a short pasta but it doesn't
matter you can do either one
it's really honestly you can use any
pasta you know there's a buccatini
shortage
you i mean you must know about that yeah
because it's not the most popular pasta
cut um in the country in this country
and so when covet hit and
and all of these factories had to lay
off workers and furlough them
they started only making the most
popular pastas the ones that they knew
they would sell
so bucatini's not on that list and so it
got cut
and so we had a shortage i have to tell
you i've been wondering why there's been
a shortage of bucatini and you just
answered this really
hot passionate mystery of mine thank you
giada
i'm just really excited because um
kachuye pepe is
one of my top favorite pastas and i've
never
made it so learning from you is like all
right so what do you what are you doing
right now because mine's a little bit of
a departure from the traditional like
we've added a little bit of pancetta
that i've already browned have you done
that all right my pancetta
is browned and ready to go oh yeah it
looks good
do you want to add the black pepper i
certainly need about one and a half
teaspoons of cracked black pepper giada
i can smell
nothing but pepper it's beautiful
um okay so i'm done with the pasta i'm
adding the pasta dump
all of the pasta into the pan okay
okay which i have now done
then i take a ladle yep you got do you
have some pasta water reserve
i certainly do always is it hot
ah it's hot okay good then start tossing
baby
all right yeah
pasta water and parmesan cheese dump it
in there and start mixing
and you'll start to see a little
creaminess come now
we are gonna add one of the two
tablespoons of butter
to that as well and just keep mixing
a lot of arm work in this you know who's
a big fan of yours is my daughter jade
who's 12.
she loves watching your movies i feel
like i know especially you and adam
sandler she finds that
so fascinating she thinks you're
hilarious will you tell her
she's super excited that he is
who you wish him to be he's such a good
heart
and so i love when people love him
because i'm like oh you love a good
person which is so important
wait how's your pasta coming because
mine's nice and creamy
how's yours look it's um you know cheese
did you add
no it's looking good but it's a little
dry it tends to get a little clumpy like
that so you just keep adding
more pasta water that's hot you just
need the pasta water pasta water add a
little bit of more butter
and make sure that the pasta water's hot
and it'll kind of come back to life i
promise
okay all right yeah it's coming it's
coming it's getting better
and then i add arugula and it's
basically done
hey don't worry i got this
add the approval and taste it all right
i'm gonna add the arugula
well it looks so pretty really we drew
it looks good yeah look it looks great
did you taste it you got to taste it
you'll never know unless you taste it
okay taste it come on we can taste it
together it's really good
and it's really really peppery and
cheesy and the arugula is beautiful i
love
arugula me too i love it i put arugula
in everything so traditionally does not
have arugula
and it does not have pancetta but to
make it a meal i need something green
and i want a little extra flavor because
this way my daughter will eat it
so there you have it my sort of spin on
kacho pepe
but i think it's really pretty and it's
absolutely divine the taste
is classic kachuy pepe it really does
taste
so beautiful well as long as the taste
is there
that's all that matters at the end of
the day um if you
want this recipe that giada made and is
so incredible to taste go to the
drewberrymore show.com